Zero is not a natural number. For example,
when we think back to the kindergarten
teacher example, she does not start
counting her children starting with zero.
She begins with one. You can think of the
natural numbers as counting numbers, and
when we count, we usually begin with the
number one not zero. But zero does have
some things in common with the natural
numbers. We can talk about there being
zero of some kind of object like cupcakes.
When considered as a single group, zero
and the natural numbers make up what we
call the whole numbers. So let's go over
the two groups we have so far. First, we
talked about the natural numbers or the
counting numbers, which are one, two,
three, and so on, all the way up to
infinity. So this includes a ton of other
numbers, too, like 89, 560, and 9,345,760
as well as every other number that we
could count from one up to infinity. The
whole numbers include all of these numbers
but also zero. So you can see that our
sets of numbers are starting to build on
each other. Which of the following
sentences accurately describe the
relationship between the natural and the
whole numbers? Please select as many as
you think are correct.